argentina es ahora el primer país
sudamericano en producir localmente la
vacuna rusa sputnik ve en medio de las
demoras presentadas en las últimas
semanas con la llegada de la segunda
dosis del componente ruso el gobierno
argentino recibió con satisfacción las
primeras vacunas producidas en la nación
muy contentos por haber recibido del
laboratorio richmond una tarea que se
vino llevando adelante durante meses y
meses de trabajo y hoy culmina con la
entrega para el ministerio de salud y la
posterior distribución de las vacunas
hechas en argentina
para hacer posible la producción el
antígeno se importa de rusia de modo que
el proceso de formulación filtrado
envasado y finalmente los controles de
calidad para la liberación del producto
serán realizados en el país sudamericano
el laboratorio richmond entregó
novecientos noventa y cinco mil 125
dosis del primer componente y 152 mil
500 dosis del segundo de la vacuna
sputnik bay producida en las
instalaciones de la compañía
sputnik de fue la primera vacuna kobe 19
que llegó a argentina en diciembre de
2020 tras un acuerdo con el gobierno
ruso de unos 30 millones de dosis
se espera que el laboratorio richmond
responsable de la fabricación local
elabora al menos 3 millones de dosis del
segundo componente con miras a
solucionar el retraso en el programa de
vacunación de este país del cono sur